you know i don't know why they don't use
garlic as one of the key medications for
the heart well actually i do there's
really no money in it but there is some
powerful information i want to share
with you today
in relationship to garlic and heart
health now of course anything i say is
not meant to diagnose or replace your
medical care check with your doctor
before implementing this but you should
at least know this information relating
to how powerful garlic is in
relationship to your cardiovascular
function so today i'm going to show you
something very simple inexpensive
garlic water garlic has shown similar
effects
in lowering blood pressure to standard
blood pressure lowering medication but
that's just the tip of the iceberg of
what garlic can do for the heart let's
cover some additional benefits first
okay it's antivirals most
colds are virus in nature so at the
first sign of a cold you should be
consuming garlic anti-fungal now if you
have a candida infection or your tongue
is like has a white film on it garlic is
the answer for that and when people take
antibiotics they end up with a
candida infection because the bacteria
was supposed to keep this
candida in check and without that it can
overgrow so garlic is very good at
countering candida which is a type of
fungus garlic is also antibacterial you
can
take it as a natural antibiotic it's
good for tb
and even aids pylori which is one of the
causes of ulcers garlic is good as an
anti-parasitic it kills worms and
parasites garlic is also powerful
in that it can hit at the root of so
many other problems simply by lowering
insulin and improving insulin resistance
which not just help your blood sugars
but they help reduce things like a fatty
liver which comes from excessive amounts
of insulin if you've been watching my
videos for any period of time you know
of all the consequences of too much
insulin there's been quite a few studies
including the one that i just did in
europe on cancer to show garlic's
powerful anti-cancer
effects garlic helps arthritis any type
of itis because it has powerful
anti-inflammatory effects so anything
like bursitis tendinitis arthritis
garlic can also increase endurance if
you're an athlete but today i'm going to
kind of focus in on the heart
primarily there's over 43 clinical
trials that show
remarkable benefits of using garlic on
the cardiovascular system in fact one
which i'll put down below showed
decreased relative risk of heart attacks
and stroke
over 50
so why would anyone not be including
garlic in their diet on a regular
basis so check this out there's a
compound called thromboxane and i don't
want to get into the chemistry of it but
this compound causes platelets to clump
forming clots okay which then can get
lodged in the heart vessels creating a
heart attack or it can pass through the
arteries up into the brain potentially
causing a stroke this compound causes
vasoconstriction okay and what we're
talking about is a spasm
of your coronary artery okay and let me
just cover that topic briefly just so
you understand what i'm talking about
there's something called unstable angina
the unstable angina is related to a
coronary artery spasm
vasospastic so the arteries actually go
into this this constriction okay and in
this type of angina you usually have
unstable plaque that can break off
and then get stuck
in other parts of your vascular system
causing a stroke or a heart attack so
sometimes it can last for 10 minutes and
it goes away and it comes back but this
is the type of angina that can occur at
rest in the middle of the night whereas
the stable angina
has a plaque that has a fibrous cap it's
more protected but can break off
triggered by certain activity either
some injury maybe exercise or something
that can break off this plaque then
causing the angina now there's various
risk factors for angina you have smoking
of course in nicotine
obesity then you have diabetes where you
have an insulin problem and the arteries
are very very stiff
high blood pressure can be a risk factor
stress can be a trigger
insulin resistance which then will cause
the inflammation inside the arteries
then you have this cascade effect of
your body trying to form a band-aid out
of cholesterol calcium and protein
alcohol is one cause marijuana can be a
trigger cocaine can be a trigger and
energy drinks some of these kids
nowadays that drink a lot of energy
drinks
combine all this sugar with this
caffeine and there's been quite a few
incidents of heart attacks in our youth
from energy drinks all right let's come
back to this compound
potent hypertension okay when this is
too high
you get high blood pressure and this
chemical compound in your body occurs
after injury and inflammation
well it just so happens there are
several things that can inhibit this
compound okay
one this is the major mechanism with
blood thinner medication even aspirin
works to inhibit this compound but guess
what garlic has several compounds
that act as a natural inhibitor to this
compound and without the side effects
okay
olive oil also can inhibit this compound
as well so when we're talking about the
effects of garlic
on heart attack and stroke we're talking
about
making sure that you don't develop clots
garlic has natural properties to lower
blood pressure reduce artery stiffness
probably because it lowers insulin
and it can help lower your calcium score
there's a really
good test that is probably one of the
best predictors of heart attacks and
it's a coronary artery calcification
test it should be zero if it's greater
than 400 or 500 or even over a thousand
that actually can predict your chances
of getting a heart attack so it's a very
very good test to get done but guess
what
garlic can help lower the calcium in the
studies that they did for statins in
relationship to trying to lower this
calcium score
they were not successful but guess what
garlic can help lower this score
garlic also can help balance out your
lipids and cholesterol as well as
help you produce more bile that then
helps to regulate the cholesterol lipids
because bile is necessary to get rid of
excessive amount of cholesterol from the
body so garlic increases bile now since
garlic is very antimicrobial because it
works on viruses funguses and bacteria
it can greatly help another thing
related to the heart called infective
endocarditis there's actually an
infection with staph bacteria
sometimes there's a fungus
biofilms that's occurring right inside
the arteries and guess what garlic can
act as a natural
antibiotic without the side effects
so that's just one more benefit garlic
can do for your cardiovascular system so
let's summarize garlic can help thin the
blood so you don't develop a clot
it's antimicrobial if there's an
infection it helps to mobilize excess
cholesterol and other lipids from your
arteries because it can increase bile
production it can help regulate the
pressure encounter this vasoconstriction
going on it can help soften the arteries
and remove any excess calcium so i don't
know about you but i don't know why
anyone wouldn't be taking garlic on a
regular basis
just for the cardiovascular benefit all
right now let's show you how to make
this very very difficult and complex
garlic water okay and i'm being
sarcastic garlic water you crush one
clove of garlic okay
you put it in some water eight to twelve
ounces of water
you add a teaspoon of extra virgin olive
oil
you let this sit for about 15 minutes
because
we want all these phytonutrients to be
released from the garlic after you crush
it and also we're putting the extra
virgin olive oil in there not just to
help you reduce that
compound we just talked about but to
also help the absorption of some of
these phytonutrients since they're fat
soluble okay and then the last part
just drink it drink it on a regular
basis now you don't have to make garlic
water you can put in your food you can
take it as a supplement there's probably
over 100 ways to take garlic just make
sure your garlic doesn't come from china
because
they sometimes grow with chlorinated
chemicals
and sometimes they use sewage as their
fertilizer so get it locally or better
yet grow it yourself now if you haven't
seen
this video on garlic it's very
interesting i put it up right here check
it out